[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui anne
baldassari cas était directrice du musée
picasso pendant dix ans de 2005 à 2014
et qui est aujourd'hui la commissaire de
la très belle exposition la collection
morozov icône de l'art moderne qui se
tient à fondation louis vuitton jusqu'au
22 février
mon second invité c'est patrice envers
celle qui fut l'une des meilleures
signatures du magazine actuel est le
rédacteur en chef de nouvelles clés il
publie nous ce faire chez albin michel
c'est sa réponse à la jeune génération
qui pensent que tout va s'effondrer
d'ici peu et elle est pleine
d'interrogations passionnante et l'on
commence tout de suite par l'image que
vous avez choisie pour illustrer notre
époque anne baldassari ça n'est pas du
tout une image de notre époque
d'ailleurs que représente l échappement
elle est derrière vous d'ailleurs je la
vois et est allée tout ça est derrière
moi
alors en fait cette image cette
photographie a été mon image fétiche
pour la construction de l'exposition de
la collection morozov il s'agit en fait
du grand salon blanc que ivan morozov
avait créé au sein sa collection et qui
avait été décoré par maurice denis entre
1907 et 1910 donc
l'image vous voyez c'est le moment de la
destruction du salon on étale à
l'issue de la rrq du catastrophique
accord germano soviétique
on est en 41 et les nazis se retournent
contre leurs alliés
la russie n est pas que l'union
soviétique et commence à bombarder le
pays dit donc les collections sont
démontée transportée on peut voir au
milieu cet espace d'accumulation de
châssis les avons été les toiles ont été
arrachés déchets si on doit également
dessus des portes les grands panneaux de
maurice denis qui ont être qu'ils
étaient marouflé à même les murs qui ont
été arrachés et on imagine dans quelles
conditions l'école et les connexions
sont partis alors on me dit soit dans
l'oural soit en sibérie en tout cas
elles ont été conservés dans des
conditions catastrophiques dans les
casses à 30 moins 40 degrés pendant près
d'une presque une décennie et
c'est un miracle en fait que ses
collections arrivent aujourd'hui à paris
nous soit redonné et voilà c'est une
image funeste mais elle est pleine
d'enseignements elle me raconte tout une
partie de l'histoire alors comment sont
justement par par ses deux frères morose
offre
qui sont-ils exactement il ya michail
c'est l'aîné qui va mourir très jeune à
32 ans
ils sont à l'industrie textile c'est son
frère cadet yvan qui va prendre le
relais
continuez la collection et la porter au
niveau extraordinaire où on peut la voir
aujourd'hui c'est à dire à peu près
270 240 tableaux français et 430 tableau
russe
alors michail d'abord et yvan ensuite
comment les voyez-vous
alors ce que je vois ce sont de très
jeunes hommes ils sont nés à une année
d'existence
1870-71 par ivan et à leur naissance
inès avec l'impressionnisme la première
exposition impressionniste et 1874
l'heure ils vivent dans un contexte
extrêmement
progressiste leur mère est à la fois un
capitaine d'industrie vit maritalement
avec un grand recteur très progressiste
sur le plan intellectuel on qui tiennent
revue elle tient un salon ils sont forts
riches mais ils ont en mémoire et de
mémoire fraîche puisque l abrogation du
servage date de 1860 et 1,10 en appel
avant leur naissance respectives
pulsions issu d'une famille de serbes
qui ne disposait d'aucun droit donc le
servage était instaurée
en russie à l'époque médiévale
uniquement au bénéfice de des grands
aristocrates et non seulement ils sont
d'origine serbe récente puisque leur a
appris l aps rampait rachète sa liberté
à partir des années 1830 60 donc peu
avant l'abrogation l'achat de sa liberté
ils achètent aussi la possibilité de
créer une petit un petit atelier
artisanal à son domicile avec sa femme
et ses enfants et c'est ainsi que
commence leur histoire industrielle donc
c'est vraiment du tissage à la main de
rubans fait sur des métiers à tisser en
longueur et d'autre part ils sont vieux
croyants donc c'est une c'est censé être
l'orthodoxie ultra-haute a remporté
d'auxi schismatique et qui a été
pourchassé par le tsarisme depuis la fin
du xviie siècle donc c'est une famille
qui n'a connu que la marginalité la
brutalité sociale l'exclusion la
discrimination et malgré cela et avec
cela et peut-être à cause de cela abati
les fondements d'une nouvelle société et
d'une nouvelle philanthropie à la rue ce
qui d'ailleurs va marquer ce qu'on
appelle le cercle d'argent alors la
collection qui bâtissent d'abord michail
il s'intéresse plus particulièrement aux
impressionnistes mais comme on l'a dit
mort jeune on y meurt en en 1903 je
crois en tout cas il ya 32 ans et
il vend lui va s'intéresser à toutes les
avant-gardes qui ce qui lui sont
contemporaines c'est à dire que quand
ils achètent des cézanne cézanne vient
de mourir quand ils achètent les fauves
les fauves viennent de faire scandale
ils achètent matisse à une époque où
aucun musée français naît l'idée
d'acheter matisse pareil pour picasso il
a un oeil absolument phénoménal c'est
lui vraiment qui choisissez td il y
passe énormément de temps en voyant
cette collection absolument éblouissant
je me suis dit mais au fond c'est vrai
que c'était moins cher à l'époque les
tableaux puisqu'il était moins connu
mais je me disais c'est une simple
question je me suis posé je pense que
vous avez dû vous la poser aussi avec la
même somme d'argent qu'ils ont consacré
à acheter tous ces chefs-d'oeuvre
s'il avait acheté des actions coca cola
ou ou des appartements à paris je pense
qu'ils auraient gagné moins d'argent
enfin du moins il aurait fait une chute
plus values moindre qu'avec les tableaux
qu'ils ont choisie en fait il vaut mieux
investir dans la peinture que dans
l'immobilier coup dans l'industrie mais
il faut avoir un deuil parce qu'à
l'époque où il achète ses merveilles il
ya énormément de deux tableaux sans
intérêt qui sont vantés par la critique
alors tout à fait d'une part les oeuvres
qu'ils achètent font partie des oeuvres
maudite de l'histoire de l'art sézanne
n'avait jamais rien vendu van gogh a
rendu un tableau au moment des recettes
un tableau qui va se retrouver dans la
collection d'yvan voilà le matisse et
picasso marre de faim littéralement et
on est quand même dans une situation où
gamer à tahiti de faim aussi donc
il n'y a pas de marché pour ces artistes
ces heures sont accumulés chez vollard
chez durand ruel d'autres on commence à
avoir des valeurs
significative pour les impressionnistes
mais ils ont eux mêmes étaient vivants
des moquées pendant
deux décennies donc en fait acheter des
oeuvres ne le font pas pour spéculer ni
pour investir ils sont cependant en tout
cas ivan un très grand industriel
puisqu'il va multiplier par trois les le
capital de familiale industriels donc on
a d'un côté une activité industrielle
extrêmement efficace de l'autre côté un
plaisir de collectionner et qui est
fondée sur la construction d'un musée ça
que c'est pas tout à fait une histoire
de goût les débats pas du tout une
histoire de goût ce que se sont mis en
tête ces jeunes hommes eux mêmes formés
à l'impressionnisme à la peinture de
très jeunes par par les peintres de
l'école des beaux-arts de moscou c'est
de bâtir un musée à la 4e' tretiakov est
qui et qui vient d'être créée par ces
deux industriels que son cercueil à
peltre yaakov et donc construisent un
musée didactique systématique de l'art
français en train de se faire que ça
leur plaise d'une certaine manière ou
pas et de chou qui n étaient engagés
dans le même programme donc c'est
quelque chose d sera moins important il
bâtit s'amuser et c'est un musée dont
les contours saint georges au moment
même où ils le regardent alors
commençons par cézanne puisqu'une salle
entière lui consacrer
je les dis les premiers acheté par yvan
c'est un an après la mort de sézanne et
je trouve que d'ailleurs ça donne une
bonne idée de la collection qui est ce
que ce qui frappe dans cette collection
c'est la couleur la couleur est
absolument extraordinaires sont les
couleurs de la peinture française de
cette époque là qui était
extraordinairement coloré et sézanne il
comprend tout de suite à quel point
cézanne est important dans la peinture
moderne parce que pour eux c'est de
l'art moderne
tout à fait c'est important parce que
c'est zen qui va le convertir à la
peinture d'une nouvelle manière il y là
c'est un amoureux de la peinture c'est
un pâtre en fait ivan morozov mais sa
mère le sacrifice et le terme à la
gestion des affaires famille donc son
tempérament d'artiste ses expériences
épiphanique de pâtre de peinture sur
deux motifs vont lui être interdit
certaine manière et c'est en retrouvant
ses amis ont décodé comprend 16 à 907
qu'il va se réconcilier avec lui-même en
fait et va suivre la voie de sézanne ont
reconstitué entrée 18 reconstitué autour
du thème du paysage
les pièces les plus importantes de l'est
pas dont le dernier paysages de cézanne
au catalogue raisonné qu'on voyait à
l'instant sur sur l'écran quelques
portraits extrêmement important des
natures mortes mais c'est quand même le
paysage qui de vous et vous avez raison
la couleur est majeur dans la collection
on peut dire que la ligne
le fil rouge à la collection d'yvon
morozov c'est la couleur de des nabis
sur un de gauguin aux nabis
au phone avec des marqueurs qui sont
picasso et quelques autres artistes qui
viennent nous tricks de la couleur on
veut revoir puisque on va voir beaucoup
de tableaux des filets de cette
collection en commençant par ce van gogh
alors que je n'avais jamais vu que
personne je pense n'a jamais vu
qu'on appelle la ronde des prisonniers
que van gogh a peint alors qu'il est à
l'aise il à saint-rémy-de-provence sondé
quelques mois avant sa mort
les célèbres 7,7 toile
elle est célèbre oui à l'islam c'est un
manga tout à fait atypique est
exceptionnel et là cette peinture a
aussi un caractère de ton portrait
puisque elle est autant référente ce
qu'il projette sur cette gravure de 7 le
motif est tiré d'une gravure de gustave
doré qui décrit une grande prison de
londres est en fait c'est newgate ce qui
est l antichambre de l'échafaud à
l'époque et
21 c est grave il va raconter une
transposition justement en couleurs en
bleu en devint sortes d'aquariums
existentielle qui où il replace
les sensations les émotions qui sont les
siennes à l'asile il avait été interné
volontairement est il écrit au bout de
quelques mois et son frère je ne reçois
un soir
ils se sont littéralement pourrir sur
place et il est enfermé on lui a tenté
de sortir et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette réclusion il va en
exprimer toute l'horreur dans cette
peinture parce que à part cette peinture
la peinture les oeuvres de cette période
ne nous parle pas de
lésiner dans les métaphores les corbeaux
les armes ou autre mais cette peinture
dit la réclusion dit
l'étouffement et l'effroi que ressent
vendeur
pierre bonnard il y en a énormément dans
cette collection et par la même occasion
bernard ont énormément admirer à la
fondation vuitton
bonnart
joue qu'elle roule pour les frères
morozov
alors bonne heure dabo d'abord achat par
mirren qui est qui va réunir trente neuf
tableaux une sorte de conte sédation
deux directions possibles d'une
collection et puis il m'a vous l'avez
indiqué et son frère va reprendre oui le
flambeau et le projet de deux bâtisses
âge de sept grandes collections
didactique et bonnart toujours dans la
ligue gogha les nabis les fauves joue
oui place très importante il est le pam
de la couleur il est très peu connu il
reconnu en france à cette époque là et
yvan brothers et du commander la
méditerranée sont rentrés ptic
monumentale des panneaux complémentaires
toujours sur le thème des quatre saisons
et ce qui est au coeur de ce
parce qu'ils en décor l'escalier d'accès
à cette galerie de peinture au coeur
c'est la lumière la lumière
méditerranéenne c'est l'insolation on
peut voir au coeur du triptyque et qui a
défilé à l'instant on est grande tache
aveugle qui est vraiment
la lumière écrase tout est un tout et
c'est cette solution qui fascine il vend
morose a
effectivement un très beau tableau il y
en a un autre que je trouve absolument
magnifique c'est le boulevard des
capucines plein par claude monet
qu'on va voir tout de suite à côté de
vous
comment le trouvez-vous ce tableau
ce tableau il est majeur à divers titres
d'abord parce que sur le plan de sa
construction on le voit pas bien à
l'écran mais sur la droite on a des
personnages ou balcon qui regardent la
foule donc on a un espace de deux
paradoxes optique entre cette foule
l'ouverture de l'espace et puis le
basculement latéral c'est quelque chose
de très impressionnant dans l'histoire
de la peinture et c'est surtout le
premier tableau impressionniste de
monnaie est représentée à l'exposition
impressionniste de 74 vient des trois
pins et qui ce qui se tient boulevard
des capucines chez nadar et senna bardet
prêté son atelier aux impressionnistes
et donc là on a une espèce d'effet de
recoupements ou depuis depuis chez badar
on regarde par y arriver voir les
impressionnistes moquer les
impressionnistes bien sûr parce que tout
paris va venir défiler chez nadar et
rire de ce que de la peinture est en
train de faire et c'est un trackpad j'ai
presque une sorte
de tableau stigmates ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que ivan morozov va
vouloir reconstituer cette première
exposition impressionniste ou avec des
tableaux qui jurait soit avec des
tableaux mono et la 335d paysages que
j'ai bâtie autour des deux grands
modèles de montgeron et du front bel et
bien elle reconstitue
peut-être les perceptions qui était
celle donnée par ses tableaux
impressionnistes en 1874 et on voit très
bien le grouillement d'un boulevard
parisien à cette époque paris c'est le
centre du monde ce moment là c'est à la
fois new york et bangkok
c'est la capitale
de l'entertainment et de la prostitution
et et là on est au coeur du pari le plus
branché
exactement d'ailleurs dans l'exposition
pour ceux qui pourront venir la voir
parce que c'est bien compliqué
aujourd'hui eh bien j'ai reposé une
grande salle et ouverture
catalogue formidable
merci mais on peut par le catalogue on
peut penser beaucoup d'autres choses et
donc dans la première salle on a des
grands tableaux austère en noir et blanc
de secondes industriels c'est qu'on
passait de vieux croyants puritains et
puis on entre dans la première salle on
est dans un vis-à-vis qui j'ai joué
aussi sur la proximité physique avec les
tableaux ce sont des femmes et elles
sont presque toutes issues du monde du
spectacle delà du cabaret et de la
prostitution aussi est on est on est
dans un monde très violent bigard est
artificielle très avec une lumière
extrêmement brutale et on peut voir
comment ces grands industriels bascule
dans le monde des maisons closes ou du
cac par du cabaret parisien et côtoie
les artistes et sa dose cet univers
interdite ce qui
est donc au coeur de votre émission
volgograd a beaucoup notamment des
toiles peintes à tahiti gauguin il faut
le rappeler c'est véritablement un body
[Musique]
ça a été un trader à succès il a vécu
sur un très grand pied il collectionnait
d'ailleurs les bonnart les peintres
impressionnistes et puis s'est lancé
après le crash de l'union générale à
corps perdu dans la pâture croyant qu'il
allait réussir aussi bien qu'à la bourse
malheureusement ça ne sera pas le cas et
mais là aussi les bars aux offres enfin
en tout cas yvon
ils achètent gogh a tout de suite quoi
alors ça m'irait en fait là qui a un
oeil incroyable qu'ils achètent et deux
premiers guga à rentrer en russie et qui
sont malheureusement l'un d'eux n'a pas
pu venir à l'exposition baptisée dans
cet état de délabrement avancé mais le
second des paysages aux deux chefs
vient de la collection de vie réelle il
va investir dans gauguin également il a
rassemblé un ensemble très important
toujours sur la période tandis celle qui
est la même période privilégiée par
sergueï chtchoukine l on avait vu cette
salle aux mêmes lui au même étage il ya
quatre ans et les choix faits à la
collection effectivement c'est comme un
diptyque ces deux collections voilà je
disais vraiment fait l'idée c'est que
les superposant mentalement on puisse
comme dans un palais de la mémoire
reconstituer ce que ça aurait pu être
sur chrome musée d'art moderne français
tel qu'il imaginait mais les choix faits
par ivan morozov sont à la fois
esthétiquement beaucoup plus percutant
que ceux faits par check in est
en cours d dans un univers tellement
pitoyable il faut se souvenir quand même
que boga et tentera de lui aussi là les
ronger par la syphilis il est en fin de
vie au sens
ses pieds pourrissent et il pas dans des
conditions
ces quelques années passées aux marques
à tahiti aux îles marquises sont
absolument très douloureuse pour lui et
on sent partout la proche de la mort ce
qui l'intéresse dans ce travail presque
nos graphiques il fait de la vie des
indigènes s'est montré toujours la
manière donc les dieux antiques lait bio
terrible anthropophage
infanticide
qui habite toujours l'univers psychique
et des indigènes est là il est présent
il est prêt à basculer et donc on est
dans un monde de peur est l'un des
tableaux majeurs de cette salle c'est le
grand bouddha qui est
aspiré par les contes barbares de
leconte de lisle et où ghoga appelle la
paix des dieux parce qu'il a il a
associé oviri de granby damas maori à
la scène et à la présence du christ donc
c'est vraiment très intéressant ce que
fait google dans cette série de
peintures est impressionnant qu ivan
morozov les et collectionner avec une
telle clairvoyance ont fait une telle
sensibilité il ya tellement de
chefs-d'oeuvre dans cette collection
malheureusement on pourra pas les voir
tous mais il suffit d'aller la voir pour
s'en apercevoir il y en a un auquel je
tiens beaucoup c'est le séchage dévoile
t pas par andré derain en 1905
un tableau quoi je trouve absolument
extraordinaire je suis demandé
d'ailleurs ça doit être saint tropez
j'imagine puisque mais j'en suis pas sûr
si c'était plutôt cool moi j'ai oublié
parce que j apprécie d été
et notamment avec matisse donc ça doit
être coolio vous avez raison oui il n'y
a pas de bataille derrière saint tropez
en tout cas certains veinards minable
des intérêts formidable et c'est un
tableau de 1905 c'est le moment même de
l'histoire du fauvisme la cage l'acajou
aux formes c'est le de 1905 ou
matisse et les fauves autour de lui don
de rein vont enfin lancer la révolution
de la couleur et passe impressionnistes
allant plus loin et au delà de
l'impressionnisme donc c'est
effectivement un magnifique tableau
complètement déroutant on a un autre de
rein qui est qui était présenté à côté
qui est toujours présenté à côté et qui
lui est plutôt oui c'est la région de
saint tropez et qui est déjà en train de
basculer vers le cubisme parce qu'on
sait que 2 de rabat va est un transfuge
sauf à l'envers picasso et le cubisme à
partir de 1907 1908 donc on a ces deux
heures en regard l'une de l'autre peut
pas éviter de montrer parce que vous
avez été la directrice du musée picasso
c'est cet acrobate pas par picasso en
1905 l'acrobate
la boule je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'on l'appelle pourquoi ce tableau est
alors d'abord île magnifique mais
pourquoi ce tableau est et est important
alors il est important parce que c'est
plutôt la configuration qui est
intéressante c'est un tableau qui est
majeur qui est né qui a été présenté
pendant très longtemps dans la
collection 4chan il est racheté par ivan
morozov viacom bel air le marchand des
cubistes schukin aussi va racheter des
oeuvres de la collection de stein donc
c'est très intéressant de voir comment
les oeuvres qui étaient bloqués chez
stein arrive à moscou elle aussi un peu
plus tardivement et puis c'est un
tableau une des clés de l'histoire du
cubisme si on nous pose la coalition de
schukin qui à 54 picasso il ad on peut
voir toute l'évolution de certaines
périodes et puis on a trois picasso
majeur chez ivan morozov toujours dans
le projet de musée commun qui sont 1901
1905 1906 et qui sont nés trois grandes
clés de l'évolution de la période
d'avant la période bleue à la période
bleue de la barbe bleue rose on bascule
à chaque fois au cubisme synthétique et
on voit comment ensemble ces deux
collections aurait bâti un vrai discours
me travaux théoriques sur la manière
dont les peintres travaillent alors moi
j'ai bien sûr j'ai présenté ses trois
tableaux de picasso mais je les ai
présenté en relation en l'occurrence
avec les offres d'essai et nist qui sont
ces russes dont on ne connaissait à peu
près rien jusqu'à l'ouverture de cette
exposition qui se réclamait de sézanne
en 1910 et qui est que ivan morozov
avait considéré comme les artistes les
plus prometteurs de cette génération et
il s'agit de mashkov kontchalovski donc
ce sont des peintures extrêmement
violente sardonique en rose yves qui
regarde vers ces années et vers picasso
et j'ai voulu là aussi ouvrir une
perspective incidente sur un champ oui
oui nous ne les connaissons pas nous ne
les avons jamais vu en france au
quasiment et ses grandes expositions
elles ne sont pas qu'une connexion de
chefs-d'oeuvre elles ne sont pas qu'un
travail académique
par le biais de ces artistes russes
regardant la peinture française au
moment même où elle était pas eh bien
nous restitue enfin je voudrais
restituer toute l'énergie qui tuera
toute l'énergie vitale aussi et
révolutionnaire que ces artistes
ressentait est ce que ça fait gronder en
russie parce que l'idée c'est que c'est
bien les interrelations et la manière
dont l'art moderne et le post
impressionniste va basculer depuis la
france jusqu'à moscou n'est pas ce que
c'est à moscou que ça va se passer à
partir de 1914 avec le constructivisme
le sucre et baptiste de ses terres à
tous les grands mouvements qu'on connaît
merci à mme baldassari il ya eu encore
plein de tableau que j'aurais pu montrer
un de baptiste un talent il y en a des
magnifiques des métis et puis à tous et
russes dont vous parlez qu'on ne connaît
pas et qui sont tout à fait étonnant à à
découvrir l'exposition se tient jusqu'au
mois de février est la fondation louis
vuitton et bien le catalogue était
formidable et pour ceux qui peuvent pas
vous voulez voir l'exposition ont fait
une pause et on se retrouve juste après
avec patrice van neer celle qui va nous
expliquer la noosphère
à transformers elle vous avez été l'une
des grandes signatures du magazine
actuel ou d'accueil très gentiment
d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de
bienveillance quand j'ai débuté en 1990
vous avez été le rédacteur en chef de
nouvelles clés et depuis vous écrivait
des livres le tout nouveau s'intitule
nous ce faire il vient de paraître chez
albin michel il répond à votre manière à
une angoisse de notre époque que dire à
nos enfants quand ils sont persuadés que
tout va s'effondrer de manière imminente
vous y avez
été confronté que le fils d'un de vos
amis on va voir ça dans dans un instant
mais d'abord on va regarder la photo
vous avez choisi l'image que vous avez
choisi pour symboliser notre époque
la terre la terre ville de nuit avec
avec toutes les lumières
qui font de notre planète une rareté
dans le cosmos parce que il est possible
qu'il y ait de la vie ailleurs mais
qu'il y ait de la vie consciente est
capable de capturer la force des fautes
ont aidé et des électrons pour illuminer
le
la surface du globe
je pense que c'est très rare vous ne
voyez pas la présence des
extraterrestres par mme obama parmi nous
que j'en sais rien mais en tous les cas
ce qui est certain c'est que nous nous
sommes sur une planète rarissime
rarissime nous avons une chance
absolument dingue et ses lumières qui
s'allument pour moi elles sont c'est de
la lumière c'est de la lumière mais au
sens aussi métaphorique on parle du
siècle des lumières les lumières est ce
que le xxième siècle sera un siècle de
lumière
ses lumières elles sont quelque part le
symbole où la métaphore de d'internet
keane qui nous relient les uns aux
autres comme si c'était un cerveau
global un cerveau global et nos sphères
du grec nous ce qui veut dire l'esprit
la conscience c'est l'idée qu'il y à une
sphère de conscience il ya une sphère de
conscience qui
et de plus en plus dense de plus en plus
puissantes espérons le de plus en plus
opérante
parce que en même temps en même temps
cette sphère
elle pose des problèmes en ce moment
elle pose de grands problèmes vous le
savez en ce moment les médias nous
racontent régulièrement ce que coûte
internet oui j'ai reçu ici même
guillaume piron son livre l'enfer
numérique l'enfer numérique c'est à dire
que ces lumières que l'on voit là à
supposer qu'elles qu'elles qu'elles
symbolisent le cerveau globale
d'internet ça coûte en énergie quoi le
1,5 fois plus que les transports aériens
c'est ça en émissions de carbone en
émissions de carbone c'est comme
l'équivalent des et comme il y avait un
pays en plus et donc il y a une tension
et c'est ça qui est intéressant une
tension entre 7,7 choses merveilleuses
extraordinaire très rare quelle espèce
humaine contemporaine on a l'habitude de
battre notre coulpe sur cette horrible
êtres humains qui détruit tout non il y
il est fantastique mais mais il arrive
incontestablement à une limite à une
limite il va falloir que cette
conscience planétaire elles prennent le
pas elle elle se métamorphose qu'il faut
qu'elle se métamorphosent parce que vous
avez choisi une autre photo ce sont ces
manifestants voilà c'est la bonne
métamorphose celle ci est bien c'est en
tous les cas le signe qu'il ya une
métamorphose parce que vous savez vous
parliez d'actuels tout à l'heure je me
rappelle qu'il ya une cinquantaine
d'années quand j'ai commencé à
travailler dans ce journal qui était
encore très très marginale on avait mis
en couverture l'écologie c'est quoi
parce qu'on savait pas on ne savait pas
quelques têtes pensantes comme rené
dumont était déjà à l'oeuvre mais la
plupart des gens ne savaient pas
aujourd'hui il y a bel et bien une
conscience planétaire alors surtout dans
les pays riches bien sûr et les pays
riches qui sont plus éclairés aussi plus
éclairés et plus gourmands et plus plus
prédateur mais voyez sur cette photo on
voit des jeunes gens ayant et en
particulier des jeunes femmes je suis
frappé par le fait que
les l'énergie féminine est
vraisemblablement
va se mobiliser
j'espère et elle est en train de le
faire on parle d co féminisme on parle
de choses comme ça c'est vrai que il y a
dans
la proche que les que les l'énergie
féminine disons
tous genres confondus l'énergie féminine
face à la nature face à la planète et
est peut-être quelque chose de nouveau
en particulier parce que les femmes on
le voit bien avec les primatologues par
exemple mais c'est vrai aussi en bio
mimétisme le l'énergie féminine nous
pousse à observer avant de casser pour
voir ce qu'il ya dedans enfin pour pour
aller vite alors que
les grands accélérateurs de particules
c'est formidable mais ce qui est très
intéressant aussi c'est d'observer
comment la nature fonctionne et je pense
que
cette génération qui arrive la
génération de nos enfants
moi je leur fais énormément confiance il
bouge un peu partout alors c'est vrai je
disais plus tôt dans les pays du nord
mais j'ai été en inde il n'y a pas si
longtemps et je trouvais qu'il y avait
beaucoup de l'association des ong de ce
à dire de plus en plus une lutte
générationnel la lutte
en faveur du climat vous avez marqué oui
oui oui tout à fait c'est comme si alors
ils nous font leurs proches nous qui
avons eu 20 ans aux alentours de 68 de
n'avoir rien fait et c ils n'ont pas
forcément tort on a été beaucoup dans le
déni dire qu'on était écolo oui on mais
on était dans le déni parce qu'on
continue à rouler avec nos caisses pour
y ont voyagé comme des fous ça continue
d'ailleurs fallu environ 9 cela dit ces
jeunes gens qu'on voit sur cette photo
je vous donne vous fiche mon billet
qu'ils ont tous un smartphone dans la
poche berkshire et donc il participe aux
problèmes à l'attention qu'on ait évoqué
juste avant et donc ces jeunes gens sont
peut-être en train de muter mais
j'espère qu'ils vont muter parce que et
et qu'ils vont trouver des solutions
parce qu'ils disent il n'y a pas de plan
b là sur cette photo il n'y a pas de
planète b il n'y a pas de planète b mais
comment vont ils faire et ce que ce que
je crains c'est que je redoute et qui
s'est souvent traduite dans la réalité
de façon brutale c'est que
la mutation la métamorphose des
consciences ne passera pas simplement
par bonne volonté il va falloir forcer
un peu les gens plaisir que non pas
c'est à dire que c'est forcé les gens à
les prospectivistes depuis une bonne
trentaine d'années disent attention on
va vers des régimes autoritaires sa de
2,2 de thierry gaudin a à jacques attali
l'ont tous dit il ont tous écrit
là-dessus attention on va vers des
régimes autoritaires mais si on va vers
ses régimes autoritaires c'est peut-être
parce que la nature la biosphère attaqué
van hool imposer le changement
climatique les collabos log peut-être
dramatise encore que les vrais ceux qui
ont inventé le mot collapse hologue
j'en parle dans ce livre
évoque la nécessité et la possibilité
d'une mutation de la conscience
collective et nous rappelle que nous
sommes une espèce
j'ai presque envie de dire un règne
d'ailleurs plutôt qu'une espèce mais
nous sommes une espèce très coopérante
quoi qu'on dise on est égoïste on est
brutal on est agressif mais on est très
très très très coopératif les uns avec
les autres plus con qu'on ne le dit
souvent
notamment parce que nous naissons comme
on le sait totalement prématuré plus que
tous les autres animaux quand un bébé né
à il peut pas se débrouiller seul mais
il lui faut mais il lui faut pour se
débrouiller seuls pâle il ne faut pas
simplement savoir marcher pour se
débrouiller seul il lui faut quoi au
moins huit ou dix ans et donc et donc il
est il est forcément imprégné de culture
il est il est forcément obligé d'être
dans l'entraidé et dans la coopération
et donc les germes sont là la tension
est énorme les défis que la nouvelle
génération et celle d'après vont devoir
relever sont gigantesques
on sait bien c'est pas la peine de faire
la liste de toutes les échéances
mais on pourrait dire c'est pas foutu
davance parce que dans nos germe même
nous sommes des coopératif justement ce
concept de nous ce faire
vous en fait l'historique patrice drevet
recel dans ce livre est l'origine il ya
deux hommes pierre teilhard de chardin
et vladimir vernadski pierre teilhard de
chardin d'abord un jésuite par la suite
qui a fait la guerre de 14 dans les
tranchées c'est ce qui m'a frappé le
premier - cc c'est à cause de ce qu'a
fait cet homme dans les tranchées de
14-18 que j'ai eu envie de m'intéresser
à tout ça et d'écrire ce livre parce que
là sur la photo on le voit il est vieux
mais quand il est jeune dans les
tranchées c'est un type qui avait été
diplômés qui était d'une famille
d'aristocrates qu'il aurait très bien pu
en 14
tirs et au flanc
pas beaucoup non c'est vrai vous avez
raison ça c'était c'était dans l'eau les
grandes familles d'aller au front mais
lui il refuse d'être officier et il veut
être brancardiers et donc pendant toute
la guerre de 14 et il a une chance
dingue parce que deux de ses frères vont
être tués et deux autres grièvement
blessés lui va passer entre les gouttes
or il sera 2 alors
ça commence vraiment en 15 mai entre 15
et 18 il est décoré mais demi de manière
à la fin d'ailleurs on lui donnera la
légion d'honneur parce que et mais il
est
médaillé au titre de la division eau
tiède au titre de la très courageux mais
très courageux et ce qui est frappant
c'est que tout en menant à bien sa
mission de brancardier il
est bien il écrit il écrit on pourrait
dire presque nuitées jours sous les
bombardements à la lueur d'une bougie il
écrit des essais alors comme il est
prêtre évidemment c'est très tournée
vers une question
spirituelle métaphysique mais il est
scientifique en même temps c'est un
paléontologue et donc et il est
darwinien ski quand même des bars qui
n'est pas fréquent chez les catholiques
de cette époque là et même chez les
catholiques encore d'aujourd'hui
il est darwinia il est persuadé que la
vie évolue en permanence il va aller
jusqu'à penser le russe aussi énormément
que que les pierres elle même évolué que
tout évolue il lit bergson il est très
influencé par la pensée de henri bergson
et
il s'interroge sur
ce qu'il est en train de faire là il est
dedans dans l'enfer il ya les massacres
autour de lui
et il parvient alors
par une un mouvement de l'esprit qui
n'est pas évident à comprendre pas du
tout évident moi j'ai lu et relu pour
essayer de comprendre en particulier
dans son livre nostalgie du front ce
qu'il ce qu'il voit en quelque sorte
parce que c'est un visionnaire à savoir
que
quelque chose va sortir de là je parlais
tout à l'heure d'une tension et et de la
nécessité pour la vie en général de
passer par des épreuves épouvantable
pour muter pour passer à une étape
suivante lui il il a l'impression que en
gros deux sets de ce carnage entre
français et allemands en particulier
va sortir quelque chose comme la société
des nations comme l'onu plus tard comme
une fratrie comme si comme si c'était un
accouchement en quelque sorte alors
il n'a pas tout de suite l'idée d'une
d'une housse faire ou n'ose faire ça
dépendra dans les phénomènes humains
dont sont alors il en parlera tout à
fait à la fin mai mais le phénomène
humain ça c'est quand il est en chine
parce que l'église qui ne l'aiment pas
le l'expédient en chine énormément
chaque fois qu'il revient on leur
jeu vous je vais accélérer parce qu'il
doit on n'aura pas le temps de dire
assez patrice selle le russe qui est
moins connu
ils se connaissent pas d'ailleurs enfin
ils sont ils sont à distance l'un de
l'autre ils ont la même idée finalement
jean la même idée ils ont aimé l'idée et
lui c'est assez incroyable il va
l'expliquer à staline lui elle expliqué
à staline en 1944 dans une lettre sa
suite à nous faire mais ça c'est juste
avant de mourir juste avant de mourir là
parce que là vous le voyez les plus
jeunes c'est un prodige de au départ de
la science saristes c'est un personnage
professeur
à saint pétersbourg du temps du tsar
mais c'est un démocrate
c'est quelqu'un qui se bat il a une
fraternité tout autour de lui c'est une
sorte de club qui a deux de deux idéaux
le féminisme ils veulent absolument que
les femmes soient à égalité avec des
hommes ça c'est en
1885 et
la démocratie sociale c'est-à-dire
éduquer le peuple éduqué le peuple à la
science et il va donc lui aussi c'est
beaucoup trop long pour détailler mais
il va falloir un jour détail dans le
livre et il va faire tout un chemin et
il va rencontrer teilhard de chardin à
paris en 1925 et c'est ensemble c'est de
leur discussion ensemble c'est de leur
discussion que jaillit le concept de nos
sphères
que femme voilà ils sont d'accord tous
les deux pour dire il y a
une nécessité pour que la technosphère
ne tue pas la vie ne tue pas là la
biosphère qui nous a engendré au départ
notre matrice de départ pour que la
technosphère toutes nos techniques
qu'est-ce qu'ils le sentent ça ils sont
mais ils font une énorme confiance à la
science sa sera une dichotomie ils
voient ça comme le monde serait gouverné
par une sorte d'intelligence
inconsciente oui au tour organisé trice
oui aux fautes en fait il remplace vieux
si vous voulez peillard de chardin
évidemment lui il a besoin absolument de
dieu comme un point à l'horizon donc on
va rejoindre
vernadski - il est beaucoup plus
immanentiste il est plus
même on pourrait dire matérialise pas ce
qu'il va revenir après après être allé à
paris rencontrer teilhard de chardin il
rentre les les soviétiques l'acceptent
ce qui est rare ici il aura même le prix
staline il aura même le prix staline
parce que il a ramené il a ramené de
parier de et de l'ouest il a ramené des
tas de choses qui intéressent énormément
les soviétiques par exemple de toute la
filière
nucléaires russes c'est lui qui l'a
bâtie au départ mais alors là nous ce
faire comment aujourd'hui pourquoi est
ce que pour vous elle est si importante
et pourquoi elle est une forme de
réponse à tous ceux et notamment dans
cette jeune génération qui pensent que
tout va s'effondrer
j'ai l'impression pour vous ça passe
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure par il
faut se perdre pour se retrouver
il y aurait une espèce de deux morts
renaissance ans quelle que soit la com 1
et nantes comme un grand rituel c'est
pas faux c'est pas faux mais avec chaque
fois un bon un peu plus loin et
de la même façon que chacun de nous
doit muter intérieurement il y à l'idée
que l'humanité tout entière doit
absolument muté comment va-t-elle le
faire comme gasquet comment est-ce qu'on
va réussir alors on parle de transition
énergétique on parle de transit toutes
sortes de transition moi je dirais que
c'est plus que des transitions ce sont
des véritable métamorphose
il faut que l'humanité là elle est
obligée parce que les échéances sont
sont lourdes
quand on vous lit pas traversé elle vous
dit au fond l'humanité elle s'est déjà
métamorphosé
ce ne serait pas la première fois leur
sans remonter à la première extinction
qui a permis justement l'émergence de de
l'humanité mais que récemment vous dites
par exemple on est beaucoup moins
violent qu'on ne l'était autrefois ça
c'est ça c'est cellulosique voilà
lorsque beaucoup de gens veulent pas
entendre mais autant vous donner cet
exemple vous dites aujourd'hui une femme
peut traverser la france tout seul
at-il
tout seul elle arrivera vivante et ça ne
leur a attaqué alors ça est petit et
inimaginables il ya encore les savait
que ça ça quand on a fait des articles
récemment encore on s'était amusé avec
feu jean-louis servan-schreiber avec qui
j'ai fait mon dernier journal
on avait fait un grand article avec les
articles et les arguments de steven
pinker validables formidable psychologue
américain mais aussi de robert munsch
bled en france de michel serres il
fallait canaliser la violence eux et à
leur sous des termes très très très
objectif c'est à dire que quels risques
frédéric courez vous au moment de votre
naissance pour que votre faim votre mort
ça soit un assassinat pur et simple par
un autre être humain eh bien ça va en
baissant on le croit pas même au xxème
siècle au xxème siècle avec les guerres
mondiales le goulag la shoah et bien
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup plus
d'humains le risque que pour le pot 4
qu'un individu finisse ses jours tué par
un autre
et bien ce risque va en baissant en
permanence ça c'est un bon signe alors
évidemment on me répond et on a raison
de me répondre oui mais allez y à une
violence latente ya une violence
symbolique qui a une violence spirituel
et le jeune homme que j'essaie de
convaincre de tout ça dans mon livre il
me dit il ya le capitalisme le
capitalisme c'est lui qui est au départ
de tout ça et il faudrait et bon
j'entends bien il est clair que
l'économie elle est tenue par le
capitalisme y compris en chine
d'ailleurs y compris en russie partout
dans le monde entier dans les pays
arabes quel est le mais
en même temps c'est il sortait deux en
même temps le capitalisme est très
violent mais ce que ce que j'veux qu'on
est obligé de constater c'est que
voilà c'est que le monde ait de moins en
moins violent
sous sa forme la plus
dure eux vous même est ce que vous vous
êtes
métamorphosé patrie andersen je vous ai
connu actuelle dans les années 90 ans
vous étiez déjà à la pointe de toutes
les recherches sur le vivant sur la
planète
vous étiez optimiste confiant dans le
progrès notamment le progrès des
sciences et est très intéressée par le
new age qui était quelque chose qui qui
déblaient qui à l'époque n'était pas une
insulte on a été pas eu des insultes
parce que ça nous semblait justement un
futur agréable et et progressiste depuis
il ya eu un nombre de cataclysme annoncé
vertigineux il ya les films de fin du
monde grâce aux progrès du numérique
est ce que vous êtes métamorphosé puis à
tous les call of the log les effondre
east dont vous parlez beaucoup dans ce
livre et que vous nous présentez
d'ailleurs puisque vous les connaissez
tous vous allez les voir est-ce que vous
même vous avez changé
eh bien
avant parce que mais ça c'était c'est un
autre sujet parce que j'étais j'aime
intéressant à la conscience parce qu'on
parle de conscience collective mais
qu'est ce que c'est que même que la
conscience d'un individu
parce que quelque part mes études sur la
fin de vie
m'avait amené à penser que
peut-être que le matérialisme occidental
se trompe quand ils pensent que la
conscience n'est jamais qu'un sous
produit de nos cerveaux et qu'une fois à
mort s'est terminée il ya plus rien
[Musique]
les les tout ce que j'avais pu récolter
au cours de mes enquêtes sur la fin de
vie y compris de ces gens qui très
paradoxalement reviennent à la vie c'est
un aspect l'irdes exprès les nerfs des
expériences de mort imminente
m'avait relativement changé moi même à
l'époque à l'époque et et je le donne en
conclusion de mon livre comme une des
démonstrations de ce que pourrait
vouloir dire aujourd'hui teilhard de
chardin c'est que teilhard de chardin
disait plus la complexité augmente et
dieu sait si elles augmentent sur cette
planète nous complexifiant tous plus la
conscience à l'intérieur des individus
augmente aussi et l'exemple des nids à
des expériences
me permets d'élus liste de l'illustré en
rappelant ceux ci c'est que jamais dans
aucune culture au monde il n'ya eu des
techniques de réanimation aussi
puissante qu'aujourd'hui dire que avec
avec la pandémie decaux vide ça serait
intéressant plus tard de voir si parmi
tous les gens qu cake qu'on a ranimé
parce qu'on ranimons ranimant ranime ça
n'a jamais existé dans aucune culture on
à part animée comme ça or parmi les gens
qui ont ranimé il ya un pourcentage un
pourcentage pas pas négligeable puisque
d'après les dernières recherches mais il
en faudrait plus de recherche c'est
environ 20 % des gens ont ranime comme
ça ils ont failli mourir on les rapports
et ils vous racontent ils vous racontent
une histoire qui 40 ans 50 ans plus tard
les faits encore pleurer et leur fait
dit mais j'ai changé j'ai changé je je
je je me rends compte à quel point
j'avais déconner jusque là les jeux
prenait au sérieux des choses sans
importance
je me suis aperçu que ce que je faisais
aux autres je me le faisait à moi même
enfin ce qui est la base de toute
éthique ces gens là l'ont vécue parce
qu'on les a simplement ranimer et ce
serait ça nous faire c'est enfin
l'avenir alors moi je me disais c'est
qu'on soir animé tous mais c'est à dire
que parce que ce que ça m'a amené à à
creuser c'est non pas qu'est ce que
c'est que la mort mais qu'est ce que
c'est que la conscience qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un changement conscience qu'est
ce que c'est que un état de conscience
modifiée on a tous connu des à un moment
ou un autre un état de conscience plus
fort
et même même un philosophe complètement
matérialiste et athées comme andré comte
sponville par exemple vous raconte dans
son livre 20 dans plusieurs livres
d'ailleurs comment un moment donné tu
n'as coup il a été transporté il il a eu
l'impression d'être d'être en fusion
avec la nature et il l'a pas raconter à
ses amis tout de suite parce que sa
rentrée dans aucune case et c'était
juste mais on on a vécu des expériences
comme ça et donc la conscience je suis
persuadé que de ce point de vue là les
bouddhistes ont raison pour pour donner
un référent neutre dans nos contrées de
dire mais la conscience et première
peut-être que peut-être que vous savez
moi j'ai interrogé à l'époque que vous
évoquez d'actuels j'étais allé voir des
grands physiciens de la mécanique
quantique qui disait vous savez qu'ils
vont étudier les particules ultime et
qui disent quand on va au niveau des
particules ultime c'est à dire des
atomes et des sous atom d-sub le monde
subatomiques obéit à des lois qui n'ont
rien à voir avec celle que nous
connaissons aristote n'existe plus c'est
tout à fait parce qu'un truc peut être
en même temps à deux endroits différents
il peut aller très très vite et est
arrêté en même temps enfin je veux dire
le paradoxe absolument énorme et bien
david baume par exemple était un des
grands qui avait été élève d'einstein
david baume me disais pour essayer de
comprendre si on connaît pas les
mathématiques non je ne fais pas les
mathématiques bien alors
sachez que ce que nous atteignons
dans ses lois très étrange de
l'infiniment petit ça ressemble à
l'émotion musicale
alors je dis à bout commença initie
réfléchissait quand une musique vous
émeut
concentrez-vous la prochaine fois que
pas au moment où la musique vous émeut
vous le passé le présent et le futur de
sa mélodie se télescopent en un point
qui échappe au temps
et alors bon j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et
quelque part ce qu'ils disaient c'était
que
on va au bout du bout de la matière on
arrive à la conscience on arrive à
quelque chose qui ressemble à la
conscience et donc la conscience voilà
le sujet mystérieux voilà qui nous
échappent et noos ou noces comme on veut
c'est la conscience donc c'est la spec
en grec en grec en grec nous faire ça
vient de paraître chez albin michel
merci patrick bonnet recel
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]